like this altitude I can run flat out
for a half-mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also do personal
question now it is
I'm a cybernetic organism living in this
episode of the Tim Ferriss shows brought
to you by athletic greens I get us all
the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day
and if you want to give athletic greens
a try they're offering a free 20 count
travel pack for first-time users I
nearly always travel with at least three
or four of these one dose bags in other
words if you buy athletic greens as a
first-time buyer you now get for a
limited time and extra $79 in free
product so check out the details at
athletic greens com forward slash Tim
again that's athletic greens comm
forward slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by uber which i use
pretty much every day
hooroo makes getting around town in the
world for that matter easier than ever
before and now uber is introducing uber
rewards a new rewards program that helps
keep Modern Life going some of you know
this already but I've used uber
thousands upon thousands of times since
2008 or 2009 when I first became an
advisor and it was even just in
prototype stage I've since used it to
save my skin in many countries where I
don't even speak the language to help
transport my dog around to save on
delivery fees from big-box retailers the
list is really countless for the number
and types of ways that I've made my life
easier with the uber as a company uber
has been doing a ton of really
interesting great things in the past
year uber rewards is going to make you
love over even more it's a brilliant
idea and you can earn points on rides
and uber eats so you earn points whether
you're staying in or going out and the
more you use it the more you get and you
unlock rewards such as uber cash which
you can apply to rides or food orders
there's a lot more though you unlock all
sorts of new benefits at each membership
level such as flexible cancellations
with gold this means you get your
cancellation fees refunded when you
rebook within 15 minutes for a limited
number of uses you get price protection
with platinum this means you get price
protection on uber X between your two
favorite places so you choose the two
places you right between the most and
during busy hours when prices might be
higher you'll be protected above a
certain amount in either direction you
might get complimentary surprise
upgrades with diamond for instance this
means that at no extra costs you request
uber X and you can get upgraded to
premium rides like black and there's a
lot more priority support party pickup
at airports getting access to highly
rated drivers all the different levels
and it goes on and on and on so you
should check it out go to brew calm
slash rewards for all sorts of examples
the more you ride the more you eat the
more you get so for the terms and to
learn more about all the ways you can
earn rewards go to Ober comm slash
rewards that's Ober comm slash rewards
out the program terms the details
examples at uber comm / Rewards chances
are you're already using uber so you
might as well opt into this and get more
out of it and if you're not these are
all the more reason to install download
and try it today hello boys and girls
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to interview an
attempt to deconstruct world-class
performers from all different fields
ranging from business to military chess
to sports everything in between and
today my guest is Catarina fake at
Catarina that's like catering - the g +
an a at ekaterina on twitter Catarina
fake is a longtime Silicon Valley
pioneer she's the co-founder of yes VC a
proceed and seed stage fund investing in
ideas that elevate our collective
humanity and we'll talk about what that
means
previously she worked at founder
collective as a founder partner served
as chair of Etsy and was the co-founder
of Flickr at Flickr Catarina and her
team introduced many of the innovations
news feeds hashtags followers likes and
so on that have become commonplace
online Catarina went on to found several
more startups finder e hunch and become
an active investor advisor and board
member helping to build companies like
Etsy and Kickstarter from their very
beginnings other investments include
cloud era Stack Overflow and Blue Bottle
coffee among many others Catarina is an
early creator of online communities and
a longtime advocate for the
responsibility of entrepreneurs for the
outcomes of their technologies Catarina
sits on the board of public goods the
Sundance Institute and McSweeney's she
was given the Silicon Valley visionaries
award in 2018 and has received two
honorary doctorates one from the new
school and the other from RISD
she's also the host of the brand new
podcast should this exists which asks
the question what is technology doing to
our humanity should this exists can be
found on Apple podcasts wherever
podcasts are found or at should this
exists calm Katharina welcome to the
show I'm super excited to be here Tim
and you've been long requested as a
guest on the show and I am
really so thrilled to finally have a
chance to spend some time together
because I feel like it's been many many
years in the making and I remember
actually when you first moved out to San
Francisco and you and I had some kind of
conversation or email exchange very
early on mm-hmm we did and I remember I
was so impressed with at one point one
of your responses because I asked if you
would I think it'd be a panelist or a
speaker set some conference might have
been South by Southwest could have been
another and you said I'm taking a year
break from conferences and I was I was
so impressed by the categorical decision
do not do any speaking engagements that
I made a mental note of that and I
there's so many places we could start
but in the process of doing homework for
this
I found mentioned and I wanted to do a
fact check on this of you having plane
tickets automatically cancelled and
other issues related to your last name
is that is that accurate did did those
things actually happen this has happened
to me many times in fact and I
discovered that it was actually the
systems at KLM and Northwest that would
throw my ticket out my last name being
fake and I have missed flights and have
spent way too many hours with customer
service trying to fix this problem and
the other thing too here's another thing
too is that I was unable for the first
two years of Facebook to make an account
there also and probably all of my
relatives so do now do you do you use a
workaround now to prevent these types of
problems or is as it has it just been
resolved at this point it has been
resolved by my not taking those airlines
anymore I'm serious like I actually will
see a flight you know on KLM or
Northwest and will not take it I'm not
even sure if those airlines are around
anymore I think yeah I'm not I'm not up
to speed on the airlines it's like
magazines and Airlines which go out of
business faster
but despite
these travel challenges you somehow
managed to land in Silicon Valley and we
were chatting before we started
recording about your I think the term
was stochastic uh-huh
path and eclectic background that you
have but could you describe for people
how you ended up in Silicon Valley did
you do Stanford MBA and study computer
science before that and and it was it
was the the objective all along how did
it how did it come to be that's actually
not my path Stanford MBA however what
happened was I was living in New York
and had spent the summer in Arkansas
rock climbing and was big into rock
climbing and had hooked up with a group
of people there and we were on our way
to Nepal to do a big climb and so I
showed up at my sister's apartment in
San Francisco she had moved there first
I am from the East Coast originally and
I had my my ice pick and my crampons on
my backpack full of gear and was
planning on doing a big climb in the
Himalayas so she being my older sister
put me up for a couple weeks in her
house and I was visiting her on the way
out to Asia but what happened was my
trip was delayed because one of our one
of our kind of head climbers had had
become injured and then the trip was
delayed and delayed and then finally it
was Avalanche season and it was no
longer possible for us to do the to do
the trek through the Himalayas and so I
ended up staying in my sister spare
bedroom at the time San Francisco was
cheap enough that people had spare
bedrooms and so I just stayed and my
delightful sister who who I love dearly
and has always taken care of me
throughout my life
her little sister shows up and you know
six months into my stay there so you
suggest to me hey Katarina you might
want to think about getting a job
[Laughter]
this being 1994 the most interesting
thing that was going on at the time in
San Francisco was the internet and so I
got started then as a web designer and
did you have a design background at that
point let's flashback six months so
you're landing in San Francisco enroute
to this climbing expedition at that
point in time what did you think you
were going to do when you grew up so to
speak or over the the following five to
ten years did you have did you have an
idea of where you thought you were going
at prior to the internet entering the
picture oh yeah I mean my background is
in art and literature mostly and from
the age of I would say probably about
ten or eleven I had decided that I was
going to be an artist and a writer and I
had studied I had actually gone I was an
art school dropout I I graduated from
Vassar with a degree in English
literature and I had applied to grad
school at Berkeley before this whole
internet thing happened and was planning
on getting a PhD in Renaissance
literature that was really my true love
I've always left poetry and the internet
which I've always had an interest in had
had a computer and had been hacking
around with it since I was young was
another alternate path that I took so I
had actually you know I'd been very
interested and had there were a bunch of
professors that I went and interviewed
with it at Berkeley
Renaissance literature was my great love
do you think that your background which
is in some respects very I suppose
atypical for someone who ends up in tech
did you feel that say literature has
provided you with with some type of
advantage or context or perspective or
other aspects of your background that
ended up really assisting you with the
both operating in the tech world and
investing in tech world do you feel like
those things have been in in any way an
advantage
I really think that people come from
outside of the industry have a
superpower that people who have lived
within the industry their whole lives or
have spent all of their time in that
mindset it just give you a superpower it
does give you an ability outside of to
be able to see things in a different way
and if you look at all of the companies
that I've been involved with and the
investments that I've made
they are companies that emphasize
creativity communication connection
collaboration and community and and a
lot of that comes from this background
in humanities that I that I have I
really am a big believer in people's
creativity flourishing when they come at
things from a different direction and
see things in a different way and in
many ways I've always encouraged
entrepreneurs and investors and people
who are interested in entering
technology to come at it from a
different field and really emphasize
those parts of themselves that are
different from the mainstream
expectation of who you're supposed to be
and what you're supposed to know where
you're supposed to go to school coming
from a different direction is almost
always an advantage in in coming from
the interrupted climbing expedition as
you did six months or so after landing
in San Francisco then being encouraged
very sounds like very gently and uh
understand understandingly by your
sister to to go consider getting a job
what did the what did the subsequent 12
months or so look like for you when you
when you stepped into that world this
was a very early stage in the internet
and there were no manuals or guides or
blog posts or anything like that to help
you shape your approach to the industry
and so you had to make it up yourself it
was a very small community of people
that were interested in the web at that
time they were all centered down
in South Park which we at that time
called multimedia Gulch which is kind of
a funny terminology it was very early
stages and so I had to teach myself HTML
I had to figure out how to design for
the Internet and it was a very
experimental DIY self education at the
time getting getting involved in that at
that very early stage it was a so it was
such a small community that I just
happened to be really lucky that my
friend my friend's roommate actually
worked at one of the very first web
companies and was able to teach me HTML
and where did where did and when did
Flickr sort of enter the scene or the
the embryonic stages of Flickr when did
that come onto the radar well that
happened it's interesting because we
were actually in the process of building
something different when Flickr came
about we everybody calls it pivoting
these days but it was it was a pivot and
came out of an unsuccessful game it was
also built during the lull after the
dot-com boom there was the dot-com bust
in 2000 2001 2002 is when it was when
things were actually looking very bad
for technology and technology businesses
and startups and the ability to get
funding we were unable to get funding
for the game that we were working on and
so Flickr was a kind of a Hail Mary that
we were able to turn into a very
successful business and then led into
the whole web 2.0 era social media as we
know it now although when we conceived
of it it was not social media it was an
online community and if we look at
Flickr as a successful Hail Mary and we
survey the landscape
of Hail Marys in the entrepreneurial
world a lot of them don't work out and a
lot of these Hail Marys don't work out
these sort of kind of death knell lasts
gasps for breath as funding is running
out often those do not work out but some
do and there are some examples of of
these these pivots whether it's Twitter
or Flickr or others that that did work
out the can you discern what perhaps the
ingredients were that made it successful
pivot slash Hail Mary is there a
particular way you guys thought about it
anything at all that that you that you
might attribute the success to you know
it's funny because there's a
conversation I once had with another
investor who said that there's some
entrepreneurs that are just so
bullheaded and stubborn and they won't
quit that companies really go out of
business when the founder just quits
when they stop when they're like I can't
take it anymore and when I was when I
was you know kind of in the valley I saw
several examples of this I was I was
dating f Williams that the Twitter
founder at the time and when it was a
con it was an amazing thing to see
actually because I've I've had
completely run out of cash you know this
is the story of startups everywhere
you're it's a race against the bank
account really and had nothing left when
he was starting blogger but he just kept
on going it was it was a miracle it was
it was amazing to watch he was
eventually his company was eventually
acquired blogger was eventually acquired
by Google Google went public he then had
more cash was able to start the obvious
Corp which then incubated Twitter and
having seen that right first hand close
up that kind of willful determination I
see that again and again and when you
see things like the pivot
that we went through I mean we were a
little bit living on you know cup
noodles and not getting paid and the
only guy that was getting paid was the
guy who had three kids on our team and
we were you talk about fumes
we were really driving on fumes and then
and then a miracle happened what
happened was we had submitted an
application to the Canadian government
Flickr was started in Vancouver Canada
and we had been rejected actually for
this for this funding for our startup
game never ending and we had apparently
checked a little box that said resubmit
next year because what happened was we
were truly going out of business I think
we had taken money from our friends and
family and all of that money had had had
been spent and I remember this it was it
was December 23rd it was two days before
Christmas a letter arrived saying
congratulations we are giving you this
grant the startup grant and it came out
of nowhere really I mean we didn't have
enough money we had like maybe a month
or two left to pay our front-end
engineer and that was it and and so this
came out of nowhere and that was what
enabled Flickr to get off the ground
that's the world yeah it was it was you
know and we were I mean it was it was a
super scrappy operation this is days
before like AWS and we just didn't have
a lot of cash and literally the the
servers were in a colocation center and
we literally had the phone number of the
woman who worked down on customs who
would call us up and say hey your new
server has arrived from Austin Texas
dell has sent you the new server we
would rush down there plug in our new
server at the colocation Center and load
up the software and keep going it was
just it was a super sketchy foundation
on
which all of this stuff was built SEC
there's there's certainly some some luck
involved with the checking of this box
but there were I would imagine also some
some good and probably some bad
decisions that were made but probably
some good decisions that were made that
in retrospect contributed to what Flickr
then became I was wondering if if maybe
we could explore one that I have just
here it under the sort of exploratory
bullets which talks about you and I
think it's George
Oates spending 24 hours a day 7 days a
week greeting every single person who
came to the site is that is that is that
true is that something you guys did sort
of manually greeting everyone who came
to the site in in an effort to build
community or what was the the rationale
behind that if that's true yeah I mean I
think that's to some degree true we had
I remember I looked back in the first
three months of Flickr
the team each had posted something like
50 posts a day in the forums on people's
photographs and had really been very
strong participants in the community as
it was being built and I really am a big
believer in this I actually wrote an
article for Wired at one time talking
about how if you read the Bible there's
you know Abraham begat you know so and
so begat so and so begat so and so and
it goes on for pages and pages and I
really do believe that the entrepreneur
is the is the Abraham of the company and
so therefore is dictating what the
practices are of the community how
everybody behaves how people respond to
other people's photos all of those
things I think are are basically how
communities are built and staying
involved and being involved and having
that conversation and being live in that
conversation all the time is a really
important part of building an online
immunity and all of this went off the
rails a bit when online community was
renamed and repackaged as social media
because then it became a media platform
in which people's attention could be
sold and as we later discovered people's
data could be harvested and also sold
and that's a very different way of
building something than building a
community from the ground up which is I
think what we were trying to do and so I
think the community even now you know
it's been acquired by SmugMug it's it's
got a new life ahead of it that's really
the foundation of why it was such a
strong community and how even after the
Yahoo acquisition and many years later
continued to be a very strong community
and a model of community online it also
strikes me how how many companies that
later become very or viewed as very
large like air B&B
in the in the beginning I mean this also
reminds me of this whether it's you know
Brian or Joe Gebbia my I know better
talk about the early days of air B&B it
was highly highly emanuel and they would
do things that didn't scale very
deliberately until they had to create a
system for it but in the beginning it
was really early high-touch to build
that community in the very early days
and it's it seems to be something that
is sometimes missed by entrepreneurs who
start something and beginning on day one
want to scale it to a million users of
10 million users or however many million
users are there any other decisions or
behaviors best practices that you had in
those early days that you think were
were critically important yeah or
mistakes either one yeah I mean it's
hard to say I mean it's funny because
when you look back at something that has
been successful I think there's a
tendency among entrepreneurs to
attribute it to some action that they
took and
[Music]
and one of the things you mentioned
earlier which I think is actually very
important is that we were
extraordinarily lucky we had we had
invented this at exactly the right time
and what had happened was all of these
things were converging at the same time
Friendster had come out and had gotten
people accustomed to the idea of having
a profile of themselves online and were
than half of the households in America
had broadband for the first time more
than half of the phones were being
shipped with a camera on them it was
just an unstoppable juggernaut because
of the time in which it was invented
right and part of that was being smart
and addressing that market but a lot of
it was also I think we were extremely
lucky and well positioned to be taken
advantage of all of these flows of
information and Bill Gross who started
Idealab and has been the progenitor of I
don't know 500 company as many many
companies he looked at the success of
what you know those businesses you know
many of them succeeded many of them
failed and tried to figure out what it
was about the companies that succeeded
that helped them to succeed and he
looked at the team execution the
financing the market they were
addressing the timing all of the things
that potentially contribute to a startup
success and what he discovered was that
more than anything
timing timing was the thing that made
this company successful and I think that
if this had happened ten years before or
10 years after even five years before or
five years after it wouldn't have had
the same momentum as it does now and I
look at this as an investor now with yes
VC my my investment firm and we're
always looking for companies that have
timed it just right that have founded
found a parade and gotten in front of it
that have are part of a movement because
when you have that kind of movement
behind you there's some kind of cultural
change that's happening there's
something that people believe very
strongly in there's a change that
society
it makes it so much easier to to get
ahead people people are more inclined to
want the product or the service they're
more inclined to talk about it it's
starting it's it's already in a in a in
a flow that's moving forward how do you
actually maybe we can look at this in a
in a specific example so let's take and
and this may not be an example of this
but it could be if we look at
Kickstarter see you you were the first
investor in Kickstarter well one of the
first one of the first and I actually
invested in it when it was still a
PowerPoint deck right it was it was not
built yet and Perry and Yancey and it
was it was actually brought to me by
sunny Bates who I think remains on the
board now it was so clear that that had
to happen and it was it was something
that you sort of felt in the culture
something that you felt around
conversations that were happening online
and this was a possibility that needed
to bear fruit it was it was it was very
it was very clear and I think a lot of
the things if you look at for example
Etsy Etsy was at the forefront of the
DIY handmade movement it was a kind of a
rebellion against big-box retail and a
return to the marketplace which has
always been a very person to person
community oriented place I've traveled
in for example in I traveled in Syria
and went to those Suk's the big market
places in Aleppo which have now been
destroyed tragically and all of that was
the kind of the one of the most ancient
market places in the world people who
would it was like a caravan sorry people
would bring their camels and you know
kind of in medieval times and form a
market there and you could see that that
was the genesis of you talk about the
Genesis
Airbnb were Flickr or all those other
companies the genesis of markets was
really sitting down having a cup of tea
and negotiating for your rug and Etsy
had that right that's he had that and
Kickstarter had that and there were this
these very kind of person-to-person
experiences that were manifested and
places like Etsy and Kickstarter and
Flickr and a lot of these products at
the very outset and I think that that's
another thing that happened at the very
beginning of Airbnb it was very much
about people coming together in a very
essential and human way and that was
what set those companies on such a
strong foundation and what did you what
and what did you see that other people
didn't see or what enabled you to see
what you saw that got UDS with say
Kickstarter or Etsy or other examples
that that might come to mind because a
lot of these companies that are name
brand now faced a lot of rejection and a
lot of noes and people didn't get it
even including people that most folks
would consider quite smart that's true
for you know Airbnb uber turn down by
hundreds of people on AngelList when it
went out and what what did you what did
you see that other people miss or did
you did you have that could be in the in
the in the companies themselves or in
the founders or anything else but what
what did you see that that got you to
yes because because I'm sorry to start
to interrupt myself and you but the
because a lot of founders will come in
and they'll although of a very high
percentage will claim that they've found
that parade right that they're in front
of these three converging trends that
are inevitably going to sweep the world
so how do you yeah how do you how do you
end up picking betting on the right
horses like we were saying earlier my
difference helped me I'm also a woman in
a male-dominated industry I'm a mom I
have there's many things about me that
are non
typical and when I was when I first saw
Etsy it was this beautiful thing and I
actually took it to Reed Hoffman who had
invested in my first company Flickr and
a bunch of other people in the valley
and they kind of lifted their eyebrows
and said okay so let me get this
straight this is a bunch of women mostly
knitting sweaters and selling it to each
other and I said exactly don't you see
the opportunity here and and I think
coming from this humanities background
where I had spent a lot of time studying
culture and society and people and what
was happening around me and human
interactions and how the culture was
changing gave me a special view into
into that world
that was missing that somehow other
people weren't seeing that was
non-typical was outside of the pattern
recognition of Silicon Valley and a lot
of the investments that I have made have
fallen outside of the typical pattern
recognition that everybody takes
advantage of in order to spot success
and I think I've always had I've always
had that my partners at founder
collective used to tell me this all the
time I would bring in deals they say
that your deals don't look like anybody
else's deals look very different the
people that you're backing the people
that you consider as potential
entrepreneurs fall far outside of what
is typically understood in the valley as
a typical investment and they said this
to me kind of over and over again like
wow where did you find these folks and
most of the time they found me and I
think part of the reason that we started
yes VC and we wanted to start a brand
new firm was because we saw that there
is a sea change happening in technology
and that people that were non-typical
people that didn't fit this the typical
pattern of an of an
entrepreneur as defined by the valley
culture were now liberated from a lot of
prejudices that they've been working
against before and if there had been an
investor in 2004 when I was raising
money for Flickr that looked like me I
would have gone straight to her but
there just weren't that many and so I
think things have changed a lot and
non-typical investors people from
outside of of the valley people that in
turn different regions people of color
women I think there's so much more
opportunity right now for those kinds of
businesses to flourish and are being
given a voice and when all of those
companies were were started it was
actually much harder to find people who
understood those business models those
founders and their orientation let's
talk about a typical and you as a
typical investor for a second because I
this is part of the reason I was so
excited to talk and I'd love to chat
about a bit more about a few things you
mentioned so you mentioned your
familiarity with culture society people
and then whatever it was five or ten
minutes ago we talked a little bit about
timing and so the question that jumped
to my mind and this is going to be a bit
of a long question so bear with me was
how could someone who wants to cultivate
that type of awareness go about
developing a bit a better perspective or
a different lens on cultural society
people and changes that end up getting
in some ways represented by these
fantastic opportunities like Kickstarter
or Etsy I've read in doing homework for
this interview that you've recommended
for entrepreneurs books like the
innovators dilemma but I also read on
your site Caterina net a paragraph you I
think you'll recognize this this is from
dozen 18 but comment on Stuart brands
work and and I'll just read this is
pretty short so through Stuart Brandt's
work beginning with how buildings learn
one of my favorite books in parentheses
and his work with the long now
foundation I learned to look at time
differently and technology differently
to think about how time is cooked into
everything we do today especially as
regards the ephemeral nature of all the
time spent on computers and in online
media so I'm curious if say how
buildings learn or Stuart brands work
would be something that you would
recommend to people who are coming out
of more of the sort of CS or a
prototypical Silicon Valley background
if they wanted to develop some of the
perspective that you have are there any
resources or books or ways that you
would suggest people explore I love that
you brought this up Tim because part of
I've heard the reason I was super
excited to talk to you about this is
because I think you and I share an
obsession with time yes and your books
are the 4-hour workweek the 4-hour body
all of these things having to do with
time managing your time thinking about
time and when you really look at it you
know kind of from the thirty five
thousand foot view time is all we've got
and I have been a time time management
is possibly the thing that I've done
most in my life in terms of generating
the kind of life that I have wanted to
lead and that comes from Minh tway back
back to when I was young and I was
actually forbidden by the Dean at my
school from taking any classes before
noon because I'm just one of those
people I work really well at night I'm a
night owl and I could not make it to my
classes in the morning I actually failed
a photography class because it was at
8:00 a.m.
I couldn't do it and I honestly believe
that one of the reasons I'm an
entrepreneur and that I have always
worked for myself is so
that I can manage my own time and have
always thought that the highest quality
of living the highest standard of living
really comes from being the master of
your own time deciding where you want to
go in the morning what you want to do
and that that is so important and
knowing that when you have the energy to
put into your work you can do that
whether or not it happens at 8:00 a.m.
or if it happens at 10:00 p.m. and I
actually gave an interview at Business
Week once about my peculiar schedule in
that I wake up in the middle of the
night between 2:00 and 5:00 in the
morning and I do three hours of work I
don't turn on the computer I I write
everything on on paper I do my best
thinking and writing and ideation during
those hours in the middle of the night
and then I go back to sleep and get up
and carry on with my day but without
that that kind of pocket of time where
I'm uninterrupted I'm offline I'm free
and liberated in a way that you just
don't get during the work day it's it's
a magical it's a magical time I've so
many questions this is right this is
great so I so I was gonna ask you about
this waking up between 2:00 and 5:00
a.m. I didn't realize that you went back
to sleep so this yeah I've been reading
up I'll explain why maybe another time
but on the history of lucid dreaming and
it appears that biphasic sleeping where
people would kind of wake up and have
have a first sleep wake up and then go
back to bed at various points in history
has been quite common it's not something
that I've done a whole lot of but could
you give us an example of what you might
work on on paper in those three hours so
you wake up at some point between 2:00
and 5:00 a.m. specifically what do you
then do is it's something that you've
already planted at the top of a piece of
paper as a prompt and you know you're
gonna work on a specific problem is it
like longhand
stream-of-consciousness what do you do
during those handful of hours I have
done it really depends sometimes I wake
up and I I've always written books so I
have I've been working on a book now for
the past three months a new book I write
sometimes poetry I sometimes just open
up my journal and start writing I can be
working on a big problem the five-year
plan for my startup or something like
that any kind of big-picture thinking
any kind of thinking that involves
creativity intuition all of that the the
kind of the the right brain and not the
left brain and I've studied all of these
people I come across these articles
there was an article that was recently
sent to me that was about this um
actually forget his name but he was an
AIA guru I think he's from Cambridge and
the thing that I did not manage to read
the whole article because I got stuck on
the very first half where it described
how this Cambridge AI genius woke up and
he didn't communicate with anybody until
noon and that he managed to have a
relationship with his family and they
had developed a language of grunts and
smiles so that so that he didn't have to
his BOTS didn't get interrupted and then
when he finally went to work around noon
he had one meeting and I was like oh my
god this is a master of time management
and preserving that flow state in your
head and preserving the ability of
yourself to think and wonder and id8 is
so precious and should be defended
ferociously at all costs and I've always
felt that way I've always had this this
very I call it like cognitive defense
really powerful cognitive defence and
this it's interesting because this also
shows up in some
the investments that we made for example
one of my theory is about cultural
movements right now is that there's this
very strong desire to simplify your life
for being constantly bombarded with
information with marketing with new
products and you walk into a grocery
store and you're confronted with a
hundred and eight different kinds of
toothpaste right and like like I was an
articles that you could be reading at
any given moment of the day and one of
the investments that we've made is this
company called public goods which
basically gives you one shampoo one
conditioner one dish soap and sends it
to your house and so you're not
confronted with the whole of this
paradox of choice right which which
which actually people want to reduce and
people want to constantly reduce the
amount of stimulation so that they can
focus and so that they can live a more
deep and fulfilled life and I really
think that in our our society today you
need to pick you know your podcast and
hopefully my podcast and eliminate all
the others if you see that I'm saying
you have to you have to focus in and
narrow down and eliminate a lot of the
noise in your life as much as possible
it's a very difficult thing to do and so
I see the time management part of our
lives as being just the crucial thing to
to defend our our space our happiness
and our individual lives I was I was
looking at your site earlier today and
found a example of removing noise and it
was a simple example but might be a
jumping-off point for exploring other
examples this is DF tube that is
distraction-free tube which is a plugin
that you use to clean up YouTube
removes the recommendations on the
sidebar the crap on the homepage inane
commentary poof and so I made a note to
use that myself are there other tools
any other tools
or books that you found helpful or
approaches that you believe very
strongly and I mean the the the waking
up sort of in the witching hour and and
working for a few hours without a screen
is I think a great example are there
then you have the very tactical kind of
micro tool like something like this
extension or there are there other
things that come to mind that youth
found or find particularly helpful when
I'm at my most flourishing and
productive self I'm actually online a
lot less and there's now all of these
tools screen time on Apple on the Apple
phone and all of these things that that
I think are great and during the periods
in which I think I'm most most
flourishing was productive what I'm
doing is I'm going online I did this I
did this for as long as I can and I fall
out of the practice occasionally but I
always try to get back is I would
schedule a time to do my email in the
morning 10:00 10:30 to 12:00 or
something like this and then again in
the evening 4:30 to 6:00 and I would be
offline as much as I could during the
times in between now a lot of us have
work that we need to do and and things
that we need to do online but to be
super disciplined about the time that
you spend online I think is is really
important and I've always done this and
I have a kind of a a notebook that I
keep next to my computer and it says WN
Oh on the cover which says when next
which stands for when next online and
you just write a list and it says you
know I need to email my accountant I
need to look up what the name of Bob
Dylan's second album was I need say go
fix this misinformation on this
Wikipedia page whatever the thing is
that you you have these urges during the
course of the day to go online and then
the next thing you know three hours have
passed and you're watching unboxing
videos on YouTube right
and you're like and you're like what
happened where do you know where did
where did it go and so I think that you
need to just get on top of that I think
that's like one really important thing
that you can that you can do this is
this is a kind of a major thing I fall
out of this all the time I am you know
you see me watching unboxing videos on
YouTube all the time and so you just
have to constantly bring yourself back
to that and realize how much of a time
suck that is and it can be and realize
also that it's it's that kind of
activity that's that's taking you away
from a life fully lived um I remember
reading an article on Quora where
somebody said I want to be an
entrepreneur as successful as Steve Jobs
and Elon Musk how do I do that
ray you know kind of you know many
people would like to know the answer to
that question and one of the respondents
was Justine musk Elon Musk Cesc ex-wife
and one of the things that she I thought
this is this is wonderful right because
like she knows firsthand actually what
it takes to become or to be Elon Musk
and she responded she said well first of
all Elon Musk would never be asking this
question in a queer forum and that
response stuck with me because it's true
right he was he was off building PayPal
his building Tesla was off doing that
and not wondering how if you seen I'm
saying it wasn't kind of reading forums
endlessly about about that but was was
out instantiating those ideas and that
really stuck with me um because I think
it's true you can spend a lot of time in
preparation and I think that's good to
it to an extent to a degree but really
really living it really being in it I
think is the most important thing yeah
it's
yeah I always have to reel myself in in
a sense because I love reading and
reading is a very socially acceptable
form of procrastinating so I don't do it
as much online although certainly guilty
of that at times but the more Kathy
Sierra a long time ago said to me or it
might have been in a presentation she
gave but I was sitting in the audience
about focusing on just-in-time
information not just in case information
and that really struck with me stuck
with me excuse me
because I have a tendency to try to
stockpile information in case of the 1%
chance that I need a B and C in the next
six months but it's not a very it's not
a great use of time they ask you about
poetry so you mentioned that sometimes
you write poetry and can correct me if
I'm wrong here but I have some of your
favorite poets including Wallace Stevens
Shakespeare Emily Dickinson why do you
write poetry what do you what do you get
out of writing poetry what does that do
for you it seems to be a kind of an
external expression of an internal state
it seems to be the recognition of and
valuing of the inner life I I read and
something that somebody had written let
me let me try to figure out who it was I
can't remember it was it was something
that I read just the other day that was
was was worrying and was very concerned
that our modern world made it impossible
for people to have an inner life that
the inner life was vanishing from the
world that our life was so much of the
time that we would normally spend with
ourselves with our dreams with our
thoughts was vanishing because it was
being filled up constantly with
stimulation entertainment and our
compulsion to be
lion and and and and basically what I
see is sort of security exploits of the
brain that the Internet has managed to
insinuate into our lives and that
poetry-writing
dreaming paying attention to those kinds
of things and the cultivation of an
inner life is something that you have to
deliberately do that you have to protect
in your in your life and make time for
and recognize as important and frankly
not do many things many of the
opportunities that present themselves
are it's just it's just terrible how
much FOMO is created by the internet
it's it's it's endless and you know
there's a thousand places that you and I
could be right now
and a thousand experiences that we could
be having and things that we could be
doing and those of us who are like you
like me like a lot of the listeners are
optimists where possible is for people
who believe in you know living life to
the fullest and the internet you know
kind of both cultivates that and makes
those opportunities available to more
and more people hopefully and and yet
too much possibility as we've discovered
shuts us down and deprives us of fully
lived experiences and so I mean it's
interesting because poetry has always
been part of my life I was a bit of a
rebel as a kid and as a student and I've
always had a very difficult relationship
with institutions I think my kind of
very anti authoritarian nature is also
one of the things that led me to
becoming in an entrepreneur and I
rebelled against these these structures
and one of the very earliest instances
of this was in first grade when all of
the other kids were learning to read and
I already knew how to read and I was
basically becoming a very
but trouble in the classroom for the
teacher because I was like impatient and
I wanted to read and so I went to the
library and I sat and I read poetry with
the librarian remember this I was I was
I was only eight five or six years old
and I still remember some of those poems
from when I was a kid and they were just
they're like kind of rhymes
here's here's one I remember once there
was an elephant who tried to use the
telephone oh no I mean the elephone who
tried to use the telephone dear me I am
NOT certain quite that even now I've got
it right it seems somehow he got his
trunk entangled in the Telefunken or he
tried to get it free the louder buzzed
the televi I fear I better drop the song
of elif up and telephone it sounds it
sounds like a great metaphor for what
happens to brains when they encounter
the internet four hours a day first do
you remember that that's incredible I
have this I have this crazy memory and I
have I have for a long time I think
since I was in my early teens I decided
that I would memorize poetry as a way of
bringing the beauty of thought and
language and I always felt that poetry
was one of the highest achievements of
human thought and beauty and a kind of
an embrace of the world and so I wanted
it to be part of me and so I started
memorizing poetry as a way of bringing
it into my unconscious as a way of
having it always with me from a very
young agent so I started memorizing
poetry as a bit of an eccentric teenager
and I have a have a lot of that love of
poetry but it's deep inside and I can
recover a lot of this poetry at times
when it's when it's needed when you're
going through some kind of crisis or
difficult times or you know depression
or like some kind of bad state you find
yourself in sudden
some Oracle from deep in the unconscious
will come out and Shakespeare will have
said exactly the right thing and you'll
then know what to do it's a kind of this
amazing strategy that I've kind of
carried with me my whole life for those
people listening who like me have
minimal exposure to poetry or at some
point we're introduced to the wrong
poetry which was just completely
confusing and seemingly designed to
remain abstract and obscure and
confusing I
are there any poets or collections you
might recommend people start with if
they wanted to dip their toe in the
water of poetry I honestly think that
there's no one poet for everybody and
that the best way to start is to just go
to poetic poetry at work it's it's just
wonderful wonderful font of poetry and
just start digging around and find what
you love I mean you mentioned some of
the ones that I love I love Wallace
Stevens I love Emily Dickinson I love
Shakespeare I wrote my thesis in college
on James Merrill I love WH Auden it just
goes on and on we could talk for hours
about we could talk for hours about this
but it's it's it's important that we do
this I'm gonna Tim if you don't mind dig
up this quote from Charles Darwin I do
not mind there's this beautiful thing
that he says I think that this is a
beautiful thing because he is a you know
he's an amazing he's an amazing
scientist and he lived the life of the
mind and Darwin's regret was that he had
become he said a machine for grinding
out facts and figures he had become a
machine like in his thinking and he said
later on in his lay
if I had to live my life over again I
would make it a rule to read some poetry
listen to some music and see some
painting or drawing at least once a week
for perhaps the part of my brain now
atrophied would then have been kept
alive through life the loss of these
tastes is a loss of happiness and I
think that's pretty powerful coming from
as great a scientist as Charles Darwin
because we live in what I call the
Technic we live in a world of kind of
mechanistic being and thought and
science and all of those passions that
throughout throughout you know since
time immemorial has sustained humanity
are getting lost somehow are their there
they're slipping away or there they're
not part of our daily life and I think
we have to deliberately put it back in
and continually put it back in and make
sure that we don't lose it do you how
much of the poetry that you write for
yourself is remains just for you and how
much of it do you show to other people I
would say a hundred percent of it is
remains just for me I have it it's
interesting because many people have
asked me this over over the years
because I've actually written a half a
dozen novels I have written probably at
this point two or three books of poetry
if it were to be in published form but I
have somehow never let any of that out
into the worlds and part of it is that
it's such a precious part of me that I
in some ways I have a very strong
tendency and desire to be successful in
the world and I read that it will be go
out into the world and will be subject
to the same laws as have led to my
success in business which it's a very
different thing and so it's funny
because I I find it everyone's like oh
my gosh
it's great you should publish this when
it's encountered and and I'm kind of
like well maybe but in the end it's so
valuable to me that in some ways if it
were to escape out into the world it
would lose some of its power yeah I
think that's very wise to protect that I
you know I run in after the after the
first after my first book I have run
into a lot of entrepreneurs who talk
about say taking as a lifestyle business
something they love doing in their spare
time on say Saturday afternoons going
surfing something like that and turning
it into a business and I'm always very
hesitant to recommend that because if
it's something that is this creative
outlet that is pure in a sense and gives
them some reprieve from the expectations
and pressures of the outside world it's
I think it's very smart to keep that for
yourself and you've talked about very
deliberately building these things into
your life and you also mentioned a name
and I'm I might be pronouncing this
correctly but WH Auden am I getting that
right yeah and there's a quote of
Auden's that I pulled up because I could
only remember the first line but I'd
love to talk a little bit about your
routines and the quote goes as follows
routine in an intelligent man is a sign
of ambition of course this applies to
everybody but routine an intelligent man
is a sign of ambition a modern stoic
knows that the surest way to discipline
passion is to discipline time decide
what you want or ought to do during the
day then always do it at exactly the
same moment every day and passion will
give you no trouble okay I've read that
you very often will eat the same entree
at certain restaurants if you decide you
like something are there are there
routines that are particular in
particularly important to you aside from
those that we've already discussed
anything that you make sure you do in
the mornings or that you make sure you
do in winding down or that you do once a
month once a week once a quarter there
any particular
teens that help you in structuring your
life in your time that you can that you
can think of I have a I have a very
idiosyncratic schedule and the the
reason for that is that I have you know
like you say I I find I find the thing
in the restaurant that I like and I
always order order it's because it's
been proven again and again that the
burden of decision-making wears you down
and that the fewer decisions that you
make over the course of the day the
better decisions that you can and the
more energy that you have left over for
the important decisions in your life
and so you know famously Albert Einstein
had one suit of which he had five
different versions or something like
this so he didn't have to think about
what he's gonna wear in the morning he
you know ate the same food like I kind
of feel as if these these patterns if
you figure out what it is that you're
happy no longer making the decisions
about I mean this is kind of one of the
one of the principles behind public
goods you know this company that I
mentioned earlier is that you don't have
to think about what shampoo to buy you
just don't have to think about it
anymore
you kind of check that box it's done
you've got a default and so building
these defaults into your life are super
important then things that you don't
want to think about anymore and whether
that be what you eat what you wear
things that you're less invested in so
that when you're in you know like my my
my witching hour
you know the hour of the wolf or
whatever you call that I'm in that state
I can go wide right I can I can make a
thousand decisions I can I have I have
freedom to go into you know dark corners
that I haven't yet explored that I can
can think really broadly and be more
creative and have dreams and you know
kind of revelations that are just not
possible if you're kind of crowded into
kind of tiny decisions all the time and
what is your
well actually let me take a step back so
you mentioned in passing something when
we were discussing poetry and how
certain poems or phrases would come to
mind at seemingly the the perfect moment
when you needed the most and you
mentioned depression very briefly is
that that's certainly something I have
some some personal experience with is
that something that you also have
personal experience with yeah I mean
when I was a teenager I was actually
quite a depressed teenager I went
through a super bad period of my life
when you know I was I was in that kind
of state that's familiar to a lot of
depressed people where I just couldn't
get out of bed in the morning and just
wanted to stay there all day and was you
know reluctant to expose myself to the
world because I felt very vulnerable and
needed to basically hide in my cave and
I think that you know many of us go
through these I mean it's a I think it's
kind of just common to the human
experience that this be a state and that
and I honestly think there's there's a
reason for it right I just I just like
the the term depression because I think
a lot of it is more it's better
described as melancholy or despair or
there's older words that describe it it
seems a clinical to talk about it in in
in the terms of depression because I
think that it's part of a fully lived
life to go through these periods of deep
unhappiness and dissatisfaction and
questioning and despair even and that
without that you kind of if you live
always on the sunny side of life I
talked about this in kind of the Jungian
sense of the shadow right you if you if
you're constantly rejecting the shadow
if you're constantly living life on the
sunny side I mean this is what happens
on social media and this is why social
media can be so
diminishing of people's humanity is that
people are always I call it social
peacocking right they're showing how
greet their life as they're showing all
of their happy moments of showing all of
their successes and not their failures
all of their triumphs and not their
doubts and basically providing a
highlights reel of their life and this
is very damaging to the psyche to
people's humanity of not acknowledging
living and frankly giving time and space
to those parts of yourself that are less
savory that are you know mistakes I see
it all around and you know you see it
all around right you kind of look at all
of your happy successful friends on
Facebook or Instagram or what have you
you know they're always going fabulous
places and doing fabulous things but
what about the shadow right like what
about the shadow there's this really
wonderful essay which I encourage
everybody to read by the science fiction
writer Ursula Le Guin about the shadow
eye I talked about it there's a blog
post on my website that's called social
peacocking in the shadow and in it I
linked to a short story by Ursula Le
Guin about the shadow which i think is a
very important part of people's humanity
which somehow is not being given space
online how I've not yet read the piece
but how would you suggest whether well
how would you suggest you can either
suggest or talk about your personal
experience people accept the shadow or
work with it without falling into a
dangerously deeper extended state of
despair like a pit of despair yeah I
honestly you know it's interesting
because I actually think that the way to
start out with that is to accept the
shadow in other people hmm because we
have this idea of other people as being
more you know rich successful beautiful
happy
they're in a better relationship there
you know they have better teeth their
hair you know they've thicker hair I
don't know what the thing is right like
some some insecurity that we have we see
in others as as something that we don't
don't have and there's a wonderful
sonnet by Shakespeare on this subject I
think it's on it what is it it's on at
29 by by Shakespeare when in disgrace
with Fortune and men's eyes I all alone
beweep my outcast state and trouble deaf
heaven with my bootless cries and look
upon myself and curse my fate wishing me
like one more rich and hope featured
like him like him with friends possessed
desiring this man's art and that man's
scope with what I most enjoy contented
least yet in these thoughts myself
almost despising haply I think on thee
and then my state like to the Lark at
break of day arising from sullen earth
sings hymns at Heaven's Gate for thy
sweet love remembered such wealth brings
that then I scorn to change my state
with kings beautiful it's a beautiful
poem and I and I think what it speaks to
is the the kind of the envy you know
wishing me like one more rich in hope
you know featured like him like him with
friends possessed and you see it all
around you especially when you're in the
state of despair and it seems as if the
world all around you is full of delight
and success and Happiness that is
somehow unavailable to you but what this
poem does is it it you know happily I
think on thee right and often this is
read as a love poem as a you know kind
of a celebration of the relationship
that Shakespeare is presumably in when
he's writing all of these when all these
sonnets but when you really think about
it you know mr. Rogers famously says
like think about all of the people that
loved you into being write those people
are not necessarily your lover but
they're your mother they're your sister
there's that teacher that saw something
in you that other people didn't see it's
your friend and it's all around you all
you just have to do is kind of stop
looking at those people that have the
thing that you wished that you had and
look to those people that saw that in
you and realize that they're all around
you so that's what that poem that's what
that poem kind of does to me and I have
you know I kind of feel as if if you
have all of these poems and kind of
they're deep inside you that they will
come to you when you need them this is
making me making me think a bit III
haven't thought of it in those terms but
only in the last few years I've started
reading some very very easy to read very
easily digested poetry by people like
you know Hafez and a lot of Sufi poetry
Rumi yeah Rumi as well and they do stick
they really do stick and they seem to
have a particular stickiness a greater
stickiness than perhaps more clinical
nonfiction write something that is
really artfully woven into beautiful
language just has a higher stickiness
factor because these poems do come to
mind at the right time just never
thought of it quite in the way that
you're presenting it do you do you or
have you found anything else useful for
embracing the shadow but not falling
into a pit of despair or if you or if
you've run into entrepreneurs who are
going through a pit of despair which is
certainly not uncommon are there any
particular recommendations that that
you've made or would be prone to make
well I think that when people are
depressed they're also in some ways
ashamed of it and I think
that's that's one of the things that
makes it feel so isolating is that we
feel that other people will judge us
that bad things could happen as a result
of our revealing these these parts of
ourselves that are so troubled or you
know despairing or unhappy or failing or
unsuccessful and that we always feel as
if we've got a present our best face to
the world and and and this can be one of
the things that makes it impossible to
get out of it and so one of the things
that's most important in especially in
our world of diminished relationships
with others is to constantly be in
communication with others to know who
our friends are to revive those lost
friendships that we've had in the past
that are very meaningful to us to resume
our closeness to others and frankly to
as Rumi would say in one of his
beautiful poems cry out in your weakness
hmm of course there's a poem for
everything but this one is you know cry
out in your weakness because there are
helpers in the world who will rush to
save anyone who cries out like mercy
itself they run towards the screaming
and cannot be bought off and if you if
you address your suffering to others you
find that the suffering is universal
that we all go through these moments of
shame and dignity depression unhappiness
failure and that anybody who's
pretending that they don't it's just not
true and you know crying out loud and
weeping Rumi says our great resources
right give your weakness to one who
helps it's a beautiful poem it's what I
think if you if you search for it's like
caught cry out in your weakness and that
is a very meaningful poem I think for
people who are suffering
because it's basically giving you
permission which I think a lot of people
need to cry out in your weakness yeah
it's I really appreciate you being
willing to talk about this and explore
it a bit because it is a constant like
you said and it and it's it's come up so
many times in this podcast whether it's
with these brutal stories of rejection
that bread and stand of humans of New
York is is telling or any number of you
know hundreds of examples that have come
up it's like you said it's a it's an
illusion and a really crippling illusion
when you're not only depressed but are
ashamed of it feeling like you're
somehow uniquely flawed because that's
just not the case so I appreciate you
being willing to to chat about this and
maybe we can we can somatically continue
on the shadow side for just a few more
minutes and then we'll shift gears but I
you have an incredible memory you have
an incredible track record I think a lot
of people listening or some people would
certainly find that very intimidating
which is part of reason also why I
wanted to bring up the depression just
to humanize the the profile a bit
are there any failures we've talked a
lot about successes and known names but
are there any failures or apparent
failures of yours that have set you up
in some way for later success any any
noteworthy failures that come to mind
and if you don't like the word failure
you could do something else yeah I mean
I it's it's perpetual it's hard to
single out a single failure we're
looking at the you know you kind of you
kind of look back at your your
miseries or failures the companies that
didn't succeed the relationships that
didn't succeed the you know great hope
that you had you know for this or for
that and kind of realize that you spent
years and years working towards some
kind of failed project or a relationship
that didn't work out or you know some
some kind of trap that you fell into and
you know it was it was a struggle to
free yourself it's funny because I think
that my orientation as a perpetual
optimist leaves me with a kind of a
sense of kind of forward motion from all
of those things I mean I do think you
know one of the things that we talked
about was how when I was a teenager I
went through a very deep depression and
um a state of despair and melancholy and
you know to use different terminology
around it and I think that always those
those periods are very formative they
are very important you go back to them
and those moments when you're at your
worst at your weakest at your least
successful at your kind of most alone
and look back at the path that you took
out of them and the ability to emerge
from them and to kind of keep going in
spite of them are some of the most
meaningful parts of your life is that
you have you have really just reached a
depths of despair and then have kind of
recovered from them and the importance
that that gives you going forward and
your strength comes from that right and
and if you're never tested and you're
never in that kind of situation you know
god help you
I mean it's not a it's not a good state
right it's it kind of the fullness of
your humanity is kind of emerging from
those depths I've always I've always
kind of felt that and without that and
you know without that experience when I
was a teenager without some of those
experiences from my childhood without
those experiences kind of like
perpetually throughout life life cycles
through highs and lows like that and
and to appreciate those periods and not
just struggle to ignore them or
eliminate them from your life is I think
one of the healthiest things that you
can do and if you're people listening
who are willing to have that broad
spectrum of experience including the
dark moments but are listening with envy
to your talk of optimism are there any
any books any I know this is kind of a
the type of question that won't die for
me but are there any tools habits books
anything that you would recommend to
people who want to cultivate a more
constant optimism if if they might have
been just beaten into cynicism by
spending too much time on the internet
or whatever it might be yeah what would
you what would you recommend to those
people I mean honestly I think that a
great deal of emphasis on long-form
reading I think you and I both embrace
this and love books and love reading and
you know I know you read you know
philosophy and Seneca and I read young
and poetry go long for I'm not short for
him go deep right and not broad I think
that this is actually a really important
thing and you know there's a dozen books
and maybe we can I can even write a list
of these and you can post it in the in
the Machine cast in the show notes
exactly I can I can I can write you like
oh my gosh a list of you know a dozen or
more books that have helped me
throughout my life oh for sure I a
hundred percent yes and yes if you can
mention any of them now you don't have
to mention all of them but I mean any
that really come to mind right now I'd
love to that was that was gonna be the
next place I went so yes
good okay well I mean let's just start
I'm I've got I'm a huge fan and part of
the reason that I'm actually probably on
the internet and love the internet so
much is because of Jorge Luis Borgess
oh yes who I'm a huge fan of and
actually was
motivation for me going online because I
had discovered a community of bore haze
fanatics in Denmark that I communicated
with very early on in my internet career
so that was that's a big one I think the
best book of his to start with is
labyrinths and it's so much about the
internet it's kind of the internet
before the internet it's a beautiful
thing
as I mentioned poetry has been a huge
part of my life I love I love all of the
ones mentioned previously WH Auden
Wallace Stevens Emily Dickinson Paul
Celan
Shakespeare of course and you know
contemporary poets as a wonderful poets
out there that I look forward to their
work
Natalie Shapiro Brenda Shaughnessy the
list goes on
I can I can put together a list for you
of poets that I love and respect I love
also the ones that you're talking about
huh Fez Rumi Khalil Gibran
like there's a lot of a lot of really
wonderful poets from the east mm-hmm
that I think bear-bear attention from us
are there any other whether it's fiction
or nonfiction long reads that you would
recommend and and for people listening
I'll definitely put all of these in the
in the show notes so you'll be able to
access all of these but if any others
come to mind jorge luis borges just
incredible in terms of the word smithing
and arts of his prose is really
staggering so I definitely second that
I'm going to bring up I use Goodreads
and good reason is actually a really
great place for people looking to
discover new books it's actually now
owned by Amazon and I put all of the
books that I've read there because I
read a lot I you know I I read at least
a book a week and I'm rereading
currently The Odyssey by Homer in a new
translation by Emma
Wilson other books that I have found to
be really great that I've read in the
past year are really wonderful book tomb
for Boris davidovich Biden Oh Lucas
Hannah versus the tree by Leland
dilettante Ethan Frome by Edith Wharton
I mean I I'm honestly I'm just kind of
going through this yeah cuz I had a
massive list the white goddess which is
a very meaningful book by Robert Graves
which is about poetry and its sources
I've reread the punished odds there is a
tremendous there's this writer who I
just adore WG Seybold I don't know if
you're familiar with him I'm not but
the emigrants by him is just an amazing
amazing book I could go on and on what
what what what books if they give you
from that list or otherwise have you
gifted the most to other people if you
gift books there's there's a couple
wonderful books that are actually
Illustrated books that I have given out
to many people and I think it's
unfortunately out of print there's one
called drawings and observations by the
artist Louise Bourgeois which is
fantastic and I've given that to so many
people as well as the principles of
uncertainty by Myrick all men
she's famously an illustrator really
beautiful books and full of just kind of
life-giving thoughts and you can tell
that these women have lived very rich
profound lives very thoughtful lives
very meaningful lives and it's there and
it's there in the books there's another
really wonderful book that's also I've
given out to a lot of people called
letters of note and that is letters kind
of basically letters that have been
collected throughout the ages wonderful
letters I've been meaning
to grab that that compendium so I'm
really glad they just mentioned that
letters have known
check and check to add to my
ever-growing reading list CC you you
were just mentioning sort of rich rich
lives and we're and beer discussing or
you were mentioning earlier the paradox
of choice that many of us face and
certainly you have more opportunities
than you could possibly ever take
advantage of in sum total why decide to
do a podcast what what was the the
catalyst or the the reasoning behind
that why why should this exists why is
why would you finite time why apply it
to that well I think that there's a
super important conversation going on in
technology right now in in the culture
in which we live that that needs to be
had I was on my friend Reed Hoffman's
podcast masters of scale and I loved
that experience
I love podcasts just in general but this
one was very gratifying for me because I
had done what I thought of as a fairly
garden-variety interview with Reed and
they had turned it into a story with
conflict and suspense and drama and made
it super interesting I loved it I loved
the podcast I thought these producers
are genius Eze and June Cohen of
waitwhat who produces masters masters of
scale started a conversation about this
new podcast and realized that the next
conversation to be had in technology was
about the human consequences of the
technology that we've been building and
I think that there has been kind of [ __ ]
going back to the theme of you know the
Sun and the shadow has been all about
the Sun and we're suddenly realizing
that the shadow which is always there
has now emerged and we've seen what
damage technology can potentially do to
our humanity and it
time for this podcast to come into being
so it just seemed as if it in some ways
this podcast is kind of inevitable it
seems as if this is a conversation
that's happening now that needs to be
emphasized and can potentially build a
future that we're deliberately building
and not lead us into unintended
consequences that we've seen happen over
and over again most recently in the
story of technology can can you describe
one of the episodes that comes to mind
just whoever is is featured what is what
is the structure of a sample episode
look like and what is what what type of
technologies or topics or entrepreneurs
are you discussing so what we do is we
find an entrepreneur who's building a
new interesting technology and some of
the interesting things have to do with
AI or CRISPR or you know gene editing
and neuroscientific in kind of
supplements to help us learn faster
you know technologies which are in
development where there's entrepreneurs
who are actually building it currently
now and we have those conversations and
then we bring in people from the
industry from outside the industry
people have different ideas
psychologists sociologists historians
perhaps and people who have a different
perspective on technology and how it
might impact our humanity and then we
have a conversation and kind of workshop
with the entrepreneur about the
potential outcomes utopian or dystopian
of this technology and how to steer it
towards its best possible future that is
really kind of the format of the show
and I think that this conversation
hopefully will become part of the
dialogue about how companies are built
how their thought about it and how at
the very beginning of building these
technologies from frankly
carried out throughout the process of
building these technologies that we not
only ask the question can this exist
because so much of technology has made
it possible for so many things to exist
but should this exists do you think
there are safeguards or externally
enforced constraints or regulations of
any type that could or should steer
technology development and company
formation or are we dependent on the
internal ethics and moral compasses of
of the people who are developing these
companies it certainly it's not it's a
false dichotomy you could have both but
I'm curious how you think how you think
about that I do think that we have in
Silicon Valley enjoyed incredible
latitude and have been basically
assuming that we have these the ability
to self-regulate I don't think that
anybody starts off this idea of being
the super villain you know III don't
think anybody kind of starts off in like
hey I like you're like I'm my kind of a
Bond villain in my mountain hideaway I'm
going to bring about the destruction of
the earth III nobody starts out that way
I think that we all start with best
intentions and as Baudelaire has said
and one of his many beautiful poems we
descend to hell by short steps and we
end up loving what we hate and hating
what we love we end up doing things that
we don't intend and that the constant
questioning the constant vigilance the
practice of asking ourselves the
question should this exist
who is this harming how do I remove bias
from my AI
how do I make sure that this doesn't
fall into the hands of the wrong people
how is it that I continually think about
the outcomes of my technology and its
effect on people and what it might do to
them and their behavior and constantly
having that as part of the process of
building something new is a very
important part of putting it on its
right track and building the kind of
future that everybody had hoped to build
from the outset I'm very much looking
forward to hearing these episodes and
also seeing how the conversations
develop over time right because it's I I
think it's an important conversation and
an increasingly important set of
questions and maybe just lens through
which to look at building and I'm
particularly interested in your crisper
episode hey maybe you could could you
could you just describe for a moment
what for people who don't recognize the
term what what crisp crisper is or what
it represents well crisper is in short
it's gene-editing
it's the ability to change people's you
know genes DNA and and this has
incredible possibility and
frankenstein-like potential so I think
that people have become very alert to
and alarmed by the possibilities the
unintended consequences of introducing
edited people edited animals edited any
form of life really you name it yeah
virus bacteria you name it viruses
bacteria introducing basically the human
touch into it you know kind of assuming
you know what what in Prior eras and in
current eras are actually thought of as
the hand of God and putting that in
human hands and the
kind of Promethean impulse that people
have to seize the power like you know
kind of Prometheus famously seizing the
power of fire from the gods and just
wrecking untold destruction upon the
earth there's just constant warnings
throughout historical literature and
Greek mythology and biblical literature
and kind of modern-day nonfiction about
what happens when we enter the
Anthropocene right we enter the the the
era of humankind manipulating the world
in a way that is potentially leading us
to conflagration and the end and you
know some say the world will end in fire
some say in ice right this is kind of
the wonderful poem by Robert Frost I
mean you know we will we will somehow
bring about our own destruction and
because of our incredible power and
ability and I think that we should take
responsibility for having that power and
you know Stewart Brand who you mentioned
earlier he was one of the progenitors of
the Whole Earth Catalog and in it he
said we are as gods and might as well
get good at it I have I have a copy of
the updated last Whole Earth Catalog
which is given to me as a Christmas
present by my mom about ten feet from my
right side right now it's a an
incredible incredible book in a very
very good statement on on Brants part I
mean it's it's really mind-boggling to
think about the promise and the perils
of many of these technologies and wait
and like famously you know Stewart Brand
is now working on bringing extinct life
forms back to life you know kind of
bringing bringing back the saber-tooth
tiger and the woolly mammoth kind of
amazingly is that and that and that kind
of awakens possibility and dreams
an excitement in the sense of you know
Wow wonder that the wonder of Technology
and the wonder of science right and then
also terror and fear yeah exciting
exciting and scary time to be alive so I
look forward to listening to you explore
it with these various entrepreneurs and
also sort of commentators let me ask one
more question it's it's sometimes one
that's tough to answer but I'll ask it
and then we'll wrap up in just the next
few minutes but the question is what I
like to ask and that is if you could
have a gigantic billboard metaphorically
speaking anywhere with anything on it it
could be a quote it could be a word it
could be a question anything
non-commercial but in the in the
interest of getting a message of some
type out to say billions of people what
might you put on that billboard it's
funny I think of the the kind of the the
basic truths as being a fairly
straightforward frankly kind of boring
statements right you know you know you
should brush your teeth regularly you
should not let not let the grass grow on
the path to your friend's door you
should be kind to one another
they sound like platitudes when you when
you when you say them when you see them
on Billboard's and yet they are
profoundly true so frankly nothing
excitement exciting mainly be kind
yeah I think it's so the two very
important words and I think that they
may be sort of inversely your capacity
for being kind maybe inversely
proportionate to the amount of time you
spend on the internet getting sort of
poked in the brain by sort of really
short form drivel that is just sort of
weaponized and commercialized which
which comes back to the long-form
recommendations in the poetry and all
these other things I really enjoy having
a chance to chat with you like this in
long-form and I thank you for taking the
time to have the conversation yeah thank
you very much
yeah no this has been a great
conversation thank you so much for
inviting me and people can find you on
twitter at katerina CA te rin a find the
podcast should this exists calm or on
Apple podcasts and anywhere else
podcasts might be found
katarina dotnet that's where they can
find your writing including the social
peacocking in the shadow and the other
posts that have come up in this episode
for people listening of course I'll add
links to everything including the books
that Caterina I would love for you to
send to send me and I'll put them in the
show notes I'll put those at tim dot
blog for it slash podcast and you can
just search Caterina or fake it'll pop
right up so anything else you'd like to
say any parting comments things you'd
like to suggest to people listening ask
of them anything at all you'd like to to
mention before we wrap up well I think
that the biggest thing that I've been
working on recently has been the should
this exists podcast so you know listen
respond subscribe that's a that's a kind
of big thing and engage in that
conversation great well we'll send
plenty of people
that direction and once again really
appreciate you making the time to have
this conversation I've really really
enjoyed it so hopefully we'll have a
chance to break bread or have coffee in
person at some point and I really look
forward to listening to the show so
thank you again for that and to
everybody listening be kind be kind
experiments go deep
not necessarily wider and check out some
of the books that I'm gonna put into the
show notes that Caterina is recommended
and until next time thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday and that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode of the Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by uber which I use
pretty much every day
lira makes getting around town and the
world for that matter easier than ever
before and now uber is introducing uber
rewards a new rewards program that helps
keep modern of life going some of you
knows already but I've used uber
thousands upon thousands of times
since 2008 or 2009 when I first became
an advisor and it was even just a
prototype stage I have since used it to
save my skin in many countries where I
don't even speak the language to help
transport my dog around to save on
delivery fees from big-box retailers the
list is really countless for the number
and types of ways that I've made my life
easier with groover as a company Uber's
were doing a ton of really interesting
great things in the past year
uber Awards is going to make you love
ever even more it's a brilliant idea and
you can earn points on rides and uber
eats to earn points whether you're
staying in or going out and the more you
use it the more you get and you unlock
rewards such as uber cash which you can
apply to rides or food orders there's a
lot more but you unlock all sorts of new
benefits at each membership level such
as flexible cancellations with gold this
means you get your cancellation fees
refunded when you leave up within 15
minutes for a limited number of uses you
get price protection with platinum this
means you get price protection on uber X
between your two favorite places so you
choose the two places you ride between
the most and during busy hours when
prices might be higher you'll be
protected above a certain amount in
either direction
you might get complimentary surprise
upgrades with diamond for instance this
means that at no extra costs you request
your ex and you can get upgraded to
Premium rides like black and there's a
lot more priority support party pickup
at airports getting access to highly
rated drivers all the different levels
and it goes on and on and on so you
should check it out go to over comm
slash rewards for all sorts of examples
the more you ride the more you eat the
more you get so for the terms and to
learn more about all the ways you can
earn rewards go to uber calm / to
rewards that's over comm slash rewards
check out the program terms the details
examples at uber comm slash rewards
chances are you're already using uber so
you might as well opt into this and get
more out of it and if you're not these
are all the more reason to install
download
and try it today this episode of the Tim
Farriss shows brought to you by athletic
greens I get us all the time if I could
only take one supplement what would it
be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with the to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try
they're offering a free 20 count travel
pack for first-time users I nearly
always travel with at least three or
four of these one dose bags in other
words if you buy athletic greens as a
first-time buyer you now get for a
limited time and extra $79 in free
product so check out the details at
athletic greens com forward slash Tim
again that's athletic greens comm
forward slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase
you
you